هي الاثناء قال وزير الداخليه تركي سليمان
سويلم استمرار العثور على ناجنه تحت
الانقاب يعزز لا ما لا بانقاذ المزيد كما
اشار الى ان 50% من المباني في ولايه
هاتاي ستزال بسبب عدم صلاحيتها للسكن
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج شخص اخر ما
زال على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاض في
قهرمان مراش وما زال نعلق الامال على
الوصول الى مزيد من الناجين زملائنا في
الميدان يواصلون العمل بكل عزم واخلاص نصف
المباني في انطاكيا اما انهارت او لحقت
بها اضرار جسيمه او هي في عداد المباني
التي ينبغي هدمها على وجه السرعه عمليات
تحديد حجم الخسائر مستمره ولا نقوم برفع
انقاض اي مبنى دون اخذ عينه منها لاجراء
فحوص كما اود ان اطمئن المواطنين باننا قد
رفعنا عدد قوات الامن العامله في المناطق
المنكوبه بنسبه ثلاثه اضعاف لضمان الامن